relationship advice we got some good
ones this week oh all right
okay nice dude brendan theo what's up
boys big fan
calling from cincinnati ohio you can see
the night
i got over my kitty cat scratch foot
fever
and i felt like it was time to get back
out there go on a date
and uh i need some dating advice
um i went on a first date to an indoor
rock climbing facility and that was just
sexual and uh but anyway the date was
great
um she's super cool way cooler than me
and
i like that skirt but i found out that
she was 28 and i am
only 21. how do you boys feel
let me know should i keep it going is it
too much
um thanks god i love you
gang gang buzz buzz
gang bro damn bro only 28 though i
thought i was gonna say she's 38 or 48
28 you're 21. who gives a [ __ ] dude
keep climbing them rocks yeah dude you
want to climb uh you want to you want to
[ __ ] you want to
you know have sex upward you don't want
to be banging downwards yeah you know
what i'm saying that gets you in trouble
if you're hitting us up saying look this
girl's 16 this girl's nine
you're going to jail yeah we can't have
you on the show bro
but you're you're still with you're
within a legal range where you're
legally
allowed to make moves on that one what's
the oldest chick you've hooked up with
deal
uh probably maybe
49
six forty six okay all right
what about yourself man uh 42
probably liar liar liar that's wild
but look man what about you nick nailed
on nick is definitely going to trump us
yeah mid-50s but i'm shocked that you
guys
god mid 50s
50s bro you [ __ ] a golden girl
oh damn bro bro you talking about a
jimmy carter supporter
uh dude you talking about a richard
nixon fan
yeah dude sign my wagon wheel bro are
you out of your mind dude
this woman uh she animated i'm probably
going to outer you probably figured out
but she animated
uh uh on uh who framed roger rabbit
she's like you're not outing anything
yeah nobody's like wait is that betty
sue
or was that her friend and she also
animated kung fu panda i met her while i
was driving for uber
wow i met her i picked i picked up her
and this uh it was a two two older women
and a guy and they were taking the guy
out because
he was going through a divorce and they
dropped him off and they were like
they're really fun and i i always got
asked out when i was ubering people
would be like oh come hang out but most
the time like the clock was running i
had to i had to drive so many hours till
sunday to make rent
but i finally had a little bit cushion
so i was like okay i'll come out have a
drink
and everything got crazy that other two
those other two hooked up in her
in her downstairs and i hooked up with
her for a couple months how'd it go down
she was like let's go upstairs young man
uh first she we went to the bar for like
hours and then when we were done we were
like oh let's all go to
irene's house and then she was like take
this [ __ ] cardigan off let's do this
and then and then she's getting these l
tits out and then one day she was just
like this is done
and i was like okay uh why was it done
she's like she didn't like your attitude
uh i don't know i she said she got in a
real relationship and i was like okay if
he if he dies hit me up oh
wow sorry do you still
communicate with her nick uh no no i i i
you know like you
you throw some lines out like months
later see what and just no response so
yeah
you mean throwing lines out like you
text like hey still alive
uh just hey what's going on to like
whoever you used to hook up with
hey how was your nap
hey you want to do dinner it's 3 45 p.m
you text me
that's crazy man uh that that woman
was still uh 18 years younger than my
dad when i was born so
uh that's not that old
she was really good looking she was
redheaded canadian uh but she sounds
awful and she had and she had all ten of
her fingers okay
all right you have to go there that's
all the crazy thing is from
probably old generations that was a big
thing if you showed up to the table
10 fingers 10 toes man that was i mean
you were basically the robert redford of
of your community also redhead you're
the paul newman of that [ __ ]
you're killing it but back to this guy
and uh i don't think he should be
worried about the
age as much as the uh the rock climbing
i don't like doing activities on dates
that could get
exhausting after a while she wants to go
camping she wants to go
rock climbing uh yeah get to see her
climb up the mountain some daisy dukes
a lot of upskirt man i think that now
that's big upskirt country if you get
over there
an upskirt is people that's real real
lonely and probably are going to go to
jail
taking pictures of people's crotches
when they don't know it's fair
and uh you shouldn't be worried though
that's not that ain't [ __ ] dude stick
with it go on a second date definitely
stick with it
cool we gotta yeah go on a second date
man you're a child dude you're lucky
that this woman will even spend time
[Music]
is